So, you might have noticed that
computers that are on the same network,
like an individual home or business or
school, usually have IP addresses
that are similar to each other.
To be more specific about it,
all of the addresses on a specific
network block share a particular prefix.
They all start the same and only differ
after some particular bit position.
And computers that are on
the same network block,
can communicate with each other
without going through a router.
But not all networks are the same size.
So when we talk about a particular
network, we have to talk not only
about its network prefix but
the length of that prefix.
A network with a longer
prefix has less of the 32-bit
address left over to distinguish
particular hosts, and a network with
a shorter prefix has more addresses for
hosts, so it's a larger network.
The network prefix length is
something that has to be chosen when
the network is set up, and it's usually
configured by whatever process assigns
addresses to the computers.
For instance, if you have
a network with a 24-bit prefix,
that means there's eight bits left
over for the host part of addresses,
we would conventionally
write this as /24.
For instance 198.51.100.0/24
network block.
But if the network prefix is shorter,
say 22-bits, then there will be 10-bits
left over for host addressing,
this would be a /22 network.
And you can't tell how long the prefix
is just by looking at the addresses.
For these addresses, either a 22 or
24 network would be a possibility.
So how many hosts can fit
on one of these networks?
Well 10-bits of host address means
two to the tenth power addresses,
which would be a 1024, except that
the top and the bottom addresses of
a network block are reserved and
the first address is usually the router.
So 1021 addresses are available for
hosts.
Similarly in a /24 network,
there would be 256 addresses but
minus those three, they're usually about
253 addresses that remain for hosts.
And why does this matter?
Sometimes misconfiguration can cause
some pretty weird problems on a server
network especially.
Things like one machine thinks that it
can talk to another machine directly,
but the other thinks that it has
to talk back through a router.
And that can cause very strange
communications problems.
Getting a good grasp of how this stuff
works can save you a lot of trouble if
you're ever setting up a server network.